So, what we learned from the last quiz is
that, when you have a negative exponent,
you can rewrite whatever term you're
dealing with, so that we're instead,
dividing by that factor inside the term.
So, negative exponents are actually veiled
ways of writing division into our term.
The way we know what we're dividing by, is
to find the factor with a negative
exponent, which is just y^-2, in this
case. And we move it underneath the
factors of the positive exponents to make
it the denominator of the term. So, on the
right side of the equation where we've
moved it, it's now in the denominator. And
we've also changed the power of the base
to be positive instead of negative. So, we
flip the sign of an exponent from negative
to positive or from positive to negative.
We need to move the factor or the base
number that the exponent is applied to, to
the opposite side of the fraction. If it's
in the top, it needs to move to the bottom
and if it's in the bottom, it needs to
move to the top, and we also flip the sign
of the exponent. So here, we change from
negative to positive. So basically, if we
have some number, let's call it x and it's
taken to a negative power, let's say,
that's -a, where a could be any number, or
really any expression. Then, this is equal
to 1/x^a.
So again, we multiply the exponent of a
number by -1. We need to switch which part
of the fraction the factor it belongs to
is part of. I know that what's on the left
side here doesn't look like a fraction,
but this is actually secretly x^-a/1.
So, anything that doesn't look like it's
part of a fraction is actually in the
numerator of your fraction, where the
denominator is 1.